well come on [ __ ] I can't hit with fake
faces
[Music]
so as you guys can tell the mukbang
today is a little bit different we're
not in my jakey little blue room we are
actually odd location at a restaurant
called nam la so why are we here you
asked this place is actually the place
of the Nexus friend Aaron he goes out
with Karen who also worked as a PA on
goon so Davis own hooks up his homies
that's what I do a lot of great reviews
on this place and I'm going to have
three of their very popular dishes that
they're known for and this place too and
you check it out on Yelp
you see they're doing you know it's a
different ship affinity spoon everybody
usually does the same stuff but they're
kind of taking that classic visit amis
food in this stepping up their
[ __ ] game to the next
[ __ ] level so first up let's
get into the first dish oh look at this
right here
so if you guys eat Vietnamese food and
you only eat the typical stuff like
spring rolls and everything else like
that you probably haven't seen this
before I actually had this because Lynn
you know my favorite jungle Asian Lynn
she actually made this for me and this
apparently is like drinking bar food
that a lot of people or so she told me
take this thing right here and I'm
talking about what I'm talking about
Wow you know I'm saying we got cilantro
on top we got this unripened mango
that's like julienned up we got peanut
Sun and we got delicious clams now what
you gonna do with this first of all I
don't know what the [ __ ] this is called
I just eat it
Daniel this is like a bunch of typos
to pronounce that for you okay
okay well you heard so if you were to
pronounce it I'm not gonna try it when
it's a chi n xu c b a and h th space MA
well without further ado we're just
gonna go right into it Aaron your father
looks like of enemies gangster
thanks I'm sweating whoa
this right here no cousin it's gonna be
the [ __ ] now I'm gonna just move this
off to the side and I'm gonna take this
fork and I'm gonna just put it right on
to this little sesame black sesame right
now if you guys have had this you
practice with the beard [ __ ] just like
the bomb No
yo this is what I like about my new
musical first of all number one flavors
are out of this world it's right it's
acidic it's salty it's motioning as I
call it seafood like and it just kind of
hits the right note it's just like a
flavor Bonanza in my mouth I love this
and I could just imagine eating this
[ __ ] next to like a [ __ ] bed to me
the river with a puppet fresh a spear
this is delicious
[Music]
you're interesting enough Aaron told me
that this is made with their own fish
sauce you have any idea how difficult to
make your own [ __ ] fish sauce that
just smells like [ __ ] shake yo Len I
know you made this for me at your house
but you need a step again because this
is loving crazy Vietnamese YouTube by
the way is more than just like the
commercial stuff that you guys just seen
your friends you all the time like
depending on what part of Vietnam that
you're from you always get different
dishes this right here if you never had
it here for a [ __ ] tree that's so
good this is like a perfect way for me
to start again crunchy right fresh it's
the peanuts - peanuts had that delicious
rounded like nutty flavor toasty flavor
I'm not skipping with my shell either
big-ass cilantro on top of there cousin
stop [ __ ] around look this right here
you know your dad's a [ __ ] thug but
you can [ __ ] cook yeah
this is good man if I like something I
[ __ ] like it if I didn't how much
straight up tell you I don't think this
[ __ ] I don't like that this is new
because this is actually like a live
with script I've never had this
restaurant you know when you like foods
when you stare at it then you will [ __ ]
it later and the mangoes too are like
the right but they not like completely
ripe so they're not that super super
crunchy crunchy mango and it's just like
just stop it has to be that in
house-made fish sauce because this is
such a unique flavor I've never had it
this good I thought would you
now you already know what this is right
here now recently I did a bump on on my
favorite sandwiches in LA the people
asked why I didn't feature suddenly
because I loved in the mismo the reason
why is because this is in a category of
its own I'm talking about fresh baguette
sliced open stuff with some of my
favorite things on earth now let's talk
about this was specifically inside we
have arranged pork belly that's in a
special sauce that nobody will tell us
to sign it and that's what you know a
restaurant is still when they hide their
recipes like it's [ __ ] gold inside
that we have a house-made aioli which
already sets it apart from the other
stuff that you're going to get and on
top of that which is my favorite part of
this [ __ ] is the house-made patent
[ __ ] love that inspect it this is a
true depiction of a fusion food is it's
like French cuisine it's with Vietnamese
cuisine and you get this delicious
[ __ ] food baby right here it's
calling to me
mmm fresh pickled vegetables nice and
punching a cilantro and this crunchy
baguette oh yeah here
Aaron I see what they do in here there's
a [ __ ] egg in there to which I
didn't even realize yeah let's talk
about this for a second
pork belly it's so different it's not
part of your mouth and that's what I'm
talking about when you brace [ __ ] you do
it nice and slow then absorb all that
flavor and it just melts in your mouth
and of course you have those bright
bitter green vegetables to kind of break
that up the crunchy baguette yeah i'ma
just shut the [ __ ] up and pick another
bicuspid
[Music]
Oh my box okay can we just have an
honest moment here real quick
a lot of abuse and all the reason why I
was a little bit skeptical about this
restaurant because the restaurant was
hella clean like a Chinese restaurant do
you want that [ __ ] to be dirty as [ __ ]
and it makes you a little skeptical you
look at the sign outside this is my
telco day I'm like typically for me I
don't like it when a lot of that's where
my plastic damaged too much I don't like
it when they innovate on things that I
think are probably better gel the way
there is but I'm telling you they step
definitely step the game up on this that
house-made pate is perfect yeah
the spices it's different does if you
had like the vid amis packed in that you
always get an all the other bunnies it's
definite not house makers all contain
same this one's a little bit different
the spices are amazing
[Music]
they're so good help
my protection of upon me is like it's
like completely [ __ ] up like just so
much if you don't like what it is what
it is women they have other options as
well and I'm pretty sure as long as you
get that in house pate on the inside
which has that kind of like livery
minerally taste which I personally enjoy
the spices and the fat content inside
kind of balance it out the mellows out
that harsh flavor there's not
traditionally what I normally get with
the funding but it's definitely fun we
have ever had straight up you know for a
fact I had to say this for last
I had to this is the quintessential
binamis dish that everybody knows now
the reason why we're featuring this year
is because they're doing something a
little bit different and a little bit
special
now if you look at the potion inside
this bowl it's not that a typical flood
time when you see like this the rare
slices of beef inside we have something
wonderful inside I'm talking about beef
rib meat with the tendon is removed from
the bone the tech in the process cook
that right there already have you said
enough to have another [ __ ] universe
because this right here cutting is gonna
be the ultimate ball of [ __ ] something
else that's unique about this squish you
leaves me a little bit skeptical once
again apparently they'll use msg because
that's [ __ ] weird I love that misty
the noodles here are if you know how
normally when you get fun you get like
that in a rice field it just actually a
bit broad so it's a little fighter and
they apparently get this fresh every day
first off I know a lot of you people out
moisten the sriracha you know the dung
and all of the [ __ ] nah man you got to
try the broth straight up first before
you add anything okay
the broth is very cleaner and the fact
that they use the rib meat there that
that kind of like when you use go into a
broth all that flavor on the side and
you can already tell because I'm either
that continent that red meat it already
like enhancer to deliver this product
and I'm telling you right now this
that's pretty [ __ ] good
cardamom cinnamon black pepper corns
it's you're right in the [ __ ] face
that's good next up you got to put that
live in to brighten it up I start off
with one line first I don't go too crazy
with it salt bay that [ __ ] like still
throw in on the Pino jalapeno spice it
up on the side and mix it up and without
further ado my friends I'm gonna get
into this news and this is what I was
talking about the noodles it's not that
typical noodle that you see it's that
flat broad one let's give this a go
I think when you innovate food you still
have to pay my homage to like the flavor
profile that makes this dish so great it
does the obviously classic flavor such
isalus but they tell of a tit which is
adjustments right quality of the green
and it kind of takes two six to another
level I'm telling you right now you come
here you get this wall of fun you're
gonna be pleasantly surprised why once
again no MSG and it's clean here there's
no cardboard on the floor which is one
good it's safe
pick it all up it wants
[Music]
see all messed up there's like this
Sydney wasn't attached to that repeat
repeats that could telephone
some people stuff Asian people love this
[ __ ] you know the cool thing about it
people are please whatever you think is
garbage is a delicacy nice see all right
there it was like slow so well the stuff
that's normally chewy and like part of
ladders to fight bills I've been through
it like nothing like butter
these are people eat anything to bull
balls duck ankle pig nose
[Music]
well I'm gonna add them up on here
obviously I don't want you to go through
but this is just something that I want
to share with you guys let me know in
the comments below if you guys want me
to do like this live on site law class
because this is a new experiment what
seem I've never had this film before
when we are trying this together if we
go to a restaurant that the road isn't
that great the restaurant has to be
brave enough to allow me to judge it
honestly I'm gonna judge it honestly and
everything that I'm here so far that
means it's pretty [ __ ] amazing they're
doing different things with traditional
food which I really really do enjoy and
I gotta say if you do come to knowledge
you will not be disappointed if you use
some of the traditions that you get
you'll definitely get those flavors but
they're doing something a bit different
I personally love this bowl of fun in
that little clan dish the one that I
couldn't pronounce the one that air is
that got starstruck on camera what he
actually forgot what it means when
that's just like the only language he
speaks that's the truth I'll see y'all
next time